now to the desperate situation at the
southern border we're getting
a new look at some of the extreme risks
immigrants are taking
to get into the u.s manuel bojorquez is
in juarez mexico manuel
what have you seen well good morning
anthony here in juarez we got access to
one smuggler's operation
along the border take a look it's
complete with ladders to get over the
wall
and peepholes to keep an eye out for
border patrol he told us he's passed 80
to 100 people over the wall over the
last six months the price
about a thousand dollars for a chance to
cross a few migrant families we spoke
with yesterday echoed the desperation
many are feeling
we hear the same themes they say they're
fleeing violence poverty
or the effects of natural disasters cbs
news has learned that due to strain
capacity at one sector of the border in
texas
customs and border protection has
started to release some migrant families
without notices to appear in court
instead those families are being given
instructions to check in with ice
at a later date gail manny thank you
very much